grant et wendel c'est la création d'un
tournoi international l'appeler le coupe
du monde qu'on voudrait c'est un
événement historique 1985
albert ferrasse alors président de
l'international rugby board annoncé la
création d'une coupe du monde de rugby
pour 1987
l'événement organisé par l'australie et
la nouvelle zélande est alors une
première
pourtant face à l'ecosse les français
débutaient leur mondial dans une
ambiance morose et surtout dans un stade
à moitié vide
ça commence comme un match du tournoi
des six nations les sa maman ni le son
ni l'ambiance quelques journalistes en
grande majorité des français pour
couvrir l'événement dans le silence et
l'indifférence presque générale une
indifférence presque générale à l'autre
bout du monde
il faut dire que cette édition se
déroule loin de l'europe et sans l'une
des nations phares du rugby l'afrique du
sud
exclu de la compétition raison de sa
politique d'apartheid
pour couronner le tout certains joueurs
français
loin de leurs familles ont même le mal
du pays s'étant de très loin de chez
nous être vivre dans un climat aussi
étendue et puis sous la pluie comme ça
c'est très agréable et il n'y a pas trop
de
l'histoire drôle de passage marrant non
dans cette vie quotidienne et qui se
passe
parmi le groupe si l'ambiance n'est pas
au rendez vous au sein du quinze de
france c'est aussi le cas chez les
journalistes présents sur place certains
dénoncé l'organisation avec virulence
je suis profondément étonné par par
l'amateurisme de la conception de cette
épreuve
bon il ya un flagrant manque de mise en
scène on se balade dans les rues on a
vraiment pas l'impression qu'il va se se
dérouler un événement très important et
c'est vraiment le dilettantisme c'est la
décontraction c'est la discrétion c'est
peut être aussi pas mal de négligence
quand on est arrivé à l'aéroport
d'auckland on a vraiment eu l'impression
de s'être trompé de pays paraît mesure
où rien ne nous rappeler vraiment qu'on
allait assister à une coupe du monde
qu'il allait y avoir quelques jours
après un événement de cette grandeur si
la première édition n'avait pas
rencontré le succès escompté la suivante
en 91 connaîtra un écho beaucoup plus
important le nombre de téléspectateurs
par exemple est passé de 230 millions en
87 à plus d'1 4 milliard en 91
[Musique]